c'est difficile de savoir dans le détail
ce qui se passe à ce moment même mais
l'Ukraine a confirmé que ils observent
les forces waltères les mercenaires
passaient la main aux forces de l'armées
régulières russes du moins dans les
zones extérieures de batmouth la
banlieue de la ville le centre-ville
semble toujours être contrôlés par les
forces Wagner mais ça c'est conforme à
ce que j'ai dit c'est un retrait qui
prendra plusieurs jours il a dit aussi
qu'il va laisser au moins deux membres
qu'il décrit comme des membres élites de
Wagner pour aider les soldats de l'armée
russe à l'intérieur de batmouth et il se
dit prêt à revenir pour défendre la
ville si les Ukrainiens contre-attaquent
ce qui est bien sur l'intention des
Ukrainiens qui disent qu'ils souhaitent
contourner la ville un peu plus que il
le contourne déjà en ce moment pour
ensuite essayer de pousser les forces
verts le centre-ville et ensuite les
bombardés du moins ça c'est comment des
commandants ukrainiens ont décrit leur
stratégie à ma collègue du service
espagnol de France 24 il y a deux jours
mais on va voir s'ils arrivent à réussir
ce coup